[Music]
this morning on the dish a chef whose
latest project isn't one restaurant but
a hotel full of them John Fraser grew up
in a Los Angeles suburb eating fruits
and veggies from his family's backyard
and fish caught up on camping trips and
he's brought a love of fresh local
produce to restaurants throughout his
career including his current New York
venues the vegetarian Knicks and the
loyal a neighborhood grocery now he's in
charge of all the dining options at Ian
Schrager 's New Times Square edition
hotel including the ninth floor terrace
restaurant and outdoor gardens fine
dining at 701 West and nightlife and
dining at Paradise Club chef John Fraser
welcome to the dish thank you having me
tell us what's on this great table I'm
gonna start from that end over there
that's mushroom carpaccio so it's thinly
sliced mushrooms over an arugula salad
mmm and it looks pretty caridy this
morning we have roasted carrots in in a
bag which steams and roasts at the same
time that's a Knicks dish here's Keira
polonaise was a vegetarian bowling a
style dish and this is a vegan
cauliflower tempura then lastly an apple
cookpot apples brown sugar oats and our
beverage drink right my favorite is a
Manhattan I like mine perfect which is
sweet and dry vermouth bitters and
bourbon Cheers
so one of the fascinating things reading
about you you studied anthropology in
college how do you go from studying
anthropology to them becoming a cook all
the way through college I was cooking
and bartending and working in
restaurants and really I was sitting in
class saying like damn I can't wait to
get to my job right and and I think that
I found a passion and some of that
misfit culture of restaurants and bars
but also making people happy right you
get this like immediate satisfaction
though it's in your mouth I can hear you
say yes and it makes me feel good I love
that you have a vegetarian restaurant in
an X I just adore anyone who takes that
leap of faith after coming off of a
career where you've worked with some of
the Giants yeah what gave you the faith
to do that yeah I had a restaurant
called dubs hell on the Upper West Side
for about a decade
and as my my diet started to shift
towards vegetables I started to bring
that into
restaurant and lo and behold a whole new
group of people started to join us
people that we hadn't seen before and I
recognized there was something happening
there at the same time people were
getting like pig tattoos and kitchens we
were starting to think about what does
it look like to feel great after dinner
right what does it make me that you're
not weighed down
right mm-hmm we won't ask you to show
your pig tattoo not a pivotal moment in
in your career which was when you went
to work at the French Laundry
yeah Thomas Keller who you said
basically changed the way you saw the
world absolutely
Thomas is a mentor and and someone that
you know he's still he's in my orbit
right and a lot of the decisions that we
make it sort of like you hear his voice
well with Thomas - yeah totally and and
it's and it's not just because of the
hard times dude it's also the really
nurturing times the moments of rough
times and kitchens are really the times
you recognize how much people care talk
about this latest project of yours the
Time Square edition Hotel which is which
is just massive it is how do you wrap
your mind around something that ranked
well first of all I have a huge team you
know it's so it's not just my mind it's
many minds it's been a great experience
working with the inche rigor and team
they're fantastic you don't really do
have a vision it's it's our job to get
it to market but it's for restaurants
and we've been sort of successfully in
succession opening them one at a time
and you have one other project that
project yeah tell me more about that
Museum yeah I mean it's my favorite
Museum in the city and you know you
obviously answer the phone when they
call it's you know the interesting part
about is that you know how do you
interject yourself into something that's
been there for so long so you tried to
kind of approach it like an exhibit
right and we'll be able to change it you
know every four months through the
seasons as an exhibit would the team
there is really great as well and again
you know introducing ourselves to a
whole new segment of people food is art
yes well and that you across Central
Park immutable evil the perfect spot
well have you signed the cool the
perfect ending if you could have this
meal with anyone past or present yeah
that one's easy for me Jane Goodall is
someone that I have
my whole life since I was just a little
kid her compassion her her way and the
way that she's she kind of approaches
life I think it's just really incredible
chef John Fraser thank you and for more
on chef Fraser and the dish you can head
to our website at CBS this morning calm